what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be talking about a
stat that i think is a little bit
misleading in the manusphere but before
i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification bell
um as you guys know i'm trying to hit 20
000 subscribers each and every one of
you helps
um and that way you're gonna be notified
of my daily videos if you bring the
notification
bell okay so i'm gonna just jump right
into it
the stat that i think is misleading is
when i hear the stat
20 of the men have access to 80 of the
women
and when i first heard the stat okay i
didn't really question it because enough
like people that i deemed credible
said the stat right which you know i
mean maybe you said the best way to go
about it but like am i going to research
every single stat
sorry i won't if someone quotes me
like miss says like i have something
wrong i'll go research it but like
just just being honest with my
viewership um
anyways and it made sense with like
stuff i'd seen in like real life
right like um it made sense because
there's a lot of girls that
you know have that i hate men men or
trash mentality
and if they're all dating the same guys
like
that totally makes sense as to
why they would feel that way um however
the more i thought about it i'm like
20 to 80
doesn't include people in relationships
so they're trying to make it
seem like only 20 of the guys are like
active um like sexually i guess or seem
like
guys like can't get girls like only 20
percent
get them but i'm researching this now
right it says
47 of all adult americans
have been married or in a committed
relationship for over
five years so
so that's half the population
um so what if that's half the pot okay
wait
married living is married
oh here we go so marriage and divorce in
america
percent of all americans 53
56 of men are married
so you add the 20
of single guys that are sexually active
and you add 53 or 56
of men that are married that's the
majority of men
are sexually active um
widow divorced i don't think it has like
long term or like real in
oh and then you take single men 30
of single men are in relationships
so i'm i'm not a stats person so maybe
someone like better with statistics
can make this make sense to me but
if you have a hundred percent of the
population half are going to be married
right
and then what percent are single so
i don't know let's take 20
30 oh i'm so dumb
so half are married half are single so
out of the half that's single 30 of
single men
are in relationships which is higher
than women
so i'm just i'm feeling like there's
some holes
in the man-o-sphere and what they're
talking about men like being so
like having no access to women because
these numbers
aren't matching up
because there's more men in
relationships than women
um so let's see 50
of men are married or in a long-term
relationship
and then 30
of the other half
are in relationships so this like this
doesn't make sense to me
and i'm wondering
if maybe there's some holes but
i am gonna look at this more because i
don't think i should do this live
but i'm just literally giving you guys
this idea that i had um
but yeah okay i'm gonna i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go but
let me know in the comments am i am i
tripping
am i tripping this seems off
this seems off so i'm let me know if i'm
tripping
in the comments um don't forget to
subscribe i'm gonna talk to you guys the
next time